So let us suppose that I go to a number of restaurants, and
have various kinds of meals and sometimes get an allergic reaction.
I do not understand why I'm getting this allergic reaction,
under what conditions do I get the allergic reaction. So go to an ER agent and
say, dear ER agent tell me, under what conditions do I get allergic reactions.
And I give all the data, shown in this table, to the AI agent. Note that there
are only five examples here, like we mentioned in knowledge-based AI we want to
do learning based on a small number of examples because that's how humans do
learning. Note also, that the first example is positive. And
that there are both positive and negative examples. That is important so
we can, construct both specializations and generalizations. How then,
may an AI agent decide the conditions under which I get allergic reaction. So
this examples are coming one at a time, and let us see what happens when
the first example comes. Here is the first example. The restaurant was Sam's.
Meal was breakfast. Day was Friday. The cost was cheap.
So from this one example, I can construct both a very specific model, which is
exactly this example. Sam's, breakfast, Friday, cheap. You can't have anything,
more specific than this. And the AI agent can also construct a more general
model. Which of course is, that it can be any restaurant, any meal, any, day and
so on. You can't construct a more general model than this.
So the most specialized model based on this one example says that, I'm allergic
when I go to Sam's and have breakfast on Fridays and the cost is cheap. And
the most general model says, I'm allergic to everything. No matter where I go,
what meal I have, on what day, and what the cost is, I feel allergic.